[Music]
contracts are everywhere not just some
huge formal agreement between large
corporations where one is going to buy
the others on although that's what
something like that looks like but you
know as a matter of fact it's everywhere
you go through them I don't know how
many times in the course of the day you
go into a parking garage they give you a
stub now that's a contract they're going
to look after your car more or less and
you're going to pay them you walk in to
your dry cleaners and you drop off your
suit and the person behind the desks
gives you a receipt well that's
important because that's how they're
going to know which suit is yours but
that receipt is also a contract and even
if there wasn't a receipt you're
dropping it off there and coming back a
couple of days later and picking up the
suit well they expect to get paid and
you expect to pay them that's a contract
you walk into a restaurant you order the
steak and chips and everything else and
then you get the check and you pay it
you can't just say well that's very nice
thank you very much for dinner see you
tomorrow
understood between you was there going
to feed you and you're going to pay them
and so it goes but gets even less formal
in that I live in New England and we
have a lot of snow storms in the winter
so what happens it snows and a bunch of
local kids come knock on your door and
say sir can we shovel out your driveway
and your walkway and so on how much 20
bucks okay
so they do it and then they knock on the
door and they have a contract with you
you owe them $20 they didn't do that as
a favor now it gets more complicated
you're out of town and it snows and
while you're out of town they come and
they shovel out your driveway and do all
that and when you come back and they say
$20 please well do you have a contract
for that or not we'll find out later
whether you do or not and what if it
snows the way it did a couple of years
ago 18 inches and they say well you know
we had a lot of work to do and they
really did this time you are $30 do you
owe them $30 all that is something we're
going to try to understand now you might
ask why do we have a MOOC on this why am
I asking you to join me for really quite
a number of sessions and quite a lot of
quite a lot of work your work my work on
the subject of contracts one thing I'm
going to tell you I'm not going to turn
you into lawyers I'm not going to teach
you how to draft a contract or deal with
a situation where somebody Sue's you or
claims that's not what I'm going to do
Oh what I'm going to do is for you to
understand what's going on as you go
through your lives in a jungle or maybe
not a jungle a forest it's not so
unfriendly of contracts it's as if I
were offering to teach you a course on
the internal combustion engine now this
wouldn't be a course on how to
fix your car when it breaks down or
doesn't break down but to know what's
going on under the hood so if your
service station then tells you it's the
transmission and that's going to go
gonna cost you fifteen hundred bucks you
know what the transmission is and you
know whether it kind of makes sense for
that to cost you fifteen hundred dollars
in other words what I'd like to do when
you're through with this is for you to
understand this part of your environment